[Music]
in his column this week rod lidl writes
in defense of stigma arguing that it can
be a good indeed vital thing durham
university student union recently
announced that it was starting safety
courses for student sex workers to break
down the stigma surrounding the
profession
shouldn't we be focused on encouraging
people not to do it in the first place
rod asks
well to discuss rod joins me now
now rod when i was in university i
didn't find the career service or the
student union all that inspiring or
helpful but you're writing your column
this week about this extraordinary
service being provided by durham's
student union tell us about it
yeah i think i think it sprung from
leicester university though i may have
got that wrong
but it's doing the rounds of some of the
universities and basically it's offering
students a couple of courses
um on uh how to
uh safely uh involve themselves in
prostitution
but
you know it's just it's just one of
those stories
from the front line of the culture war
which sort of explodes like how it's
earned
you see it and you can't resist it
uh and their argument is that uh
uh that that some students because
they're skint uh resort to uh stuff like
having sugar daddies or
or uh or or indeed prostitution um and
that they ought to be able to do it
safely so that's putting it aside that
the university uh puts it or the
students union puts it um
they also say as they always will say
that their aim is to destigmatize
uh
sex workers
and that's that's really what the column
is about the notion
that it would be a good idea to
destigmatize prostitution well rod i
think we do have to say sex work now as
the
sanitized way of saying that um do you
think it's that's what it's it's a
ludicrous title
that whoring is a better title uh but of
course you can't get away with that
anymore but but you see the way in which
the grammar is policed
moves you to a position where you are
beginning to destigmatize something
which really really shouldn't be
destigmatized because it's dangerous
it's immoral it's filthy it's dangerous
again and it's
exploitative and sexist you know
i don't know how much more bad it could
be you know you need to distinguish you
need to destigmatize that no you need a
stigma for it i guess it's like taking
it to the extremist notion that some
modern feminists have that you know
women are in control of their bodies if
they want to be sexy if they want to
wear skimpy clothes that's their choice
and therefore if they want to sell their
body that's also their choice um i guess
you're not a body positive feminist then
rod
well there are some feminists well i
think feminism is is
and has historically been split on this
and and i guess i come from
that wave of feminism which was around
in the 70s
um
which i think was more potent than the
kind of revisionist feminism we have now
um so i'm kind of down with the turfs
most of whom were part of that seventies
uh they're shalom of firestone and
uh people like that wonderful writers
various service writers um
uh
and most of them most of the family
signing then would have been
as grotesquely appalled by prostitution
as you know i am today um and i would
have thought you were cindy you know
it's
it's uh it's exploitative it's
objectifying women it's also filthy and
immoral you know
that's how it seems to me now if you
want to destigmatize it um i i don't
quite see how you can do that because
it's transactional it's unpleasant the
only argument i've heard from feminists
more recently which which
supports
prostitution is that
effectively marriage is prostitution
you know so i i have heard that before
now well only if you get money out of
your marriage well
the old traditional idea of marriage
being that the woman
became effectively the husband's chattel
uh which is the old you know
19th century view of the uh of the
of marriage which was created of course
the the modern marriage was created
largely at the time of the industrial
revolution um and you know the manner
and the money the woman was there to
breed and look after the house and and
so i can i could kind of see where
feminism would come from in in arguing
the toss over that but but but but i
don't think you then go full blast and
say but that means prostitution should
should be allowed because you know it's
uh two wrongs don't make a right yeah
rod i guess what i do think is that if
people are going to be doing this kind
of work and you know in some ways as the
oldest profession isn't it then i kind
of want young people to be doing it in a
safe way or all people to be doing it is
safe or if it's going to happen at all
then why not make it safer do you think
that's a ludicrous position no no
because it legitimizes it because saying
this is how to do it legitimizes an
appalling
an appalling thing i mean
students also shoplift
should they be given advice on how to
shoplift properly and how to do so in
comparative safety and avoid the
security guard i mean
no you you don't do things like that
because you have to keep some sort of
moral standard and it is about moral
standards and nobody needs moral
standards more than you know the
generation which are now in university
we all did and i did
and rode your column moves on more
widely as you say to other types of
things that should be stigmatized can
you tell us about your argument there
well the argument is is is two folks
firstly that
that
there's been a howl around for the last
30 to 40 years about various things we
need to destigmatize
and in almost every case the
de-stigmatizing of those things has made
society worse and made the outcomes for
individuals worse
the thing about stigma is that it's not
something from the government you know
it's not
something which comes from academia it's
something which is kind of
from the people
and it's not arbitrary it's based upon
logic and common sense even if it is
imbued with christian morality and it's
it's it's a means of society
suggesting to people that the things
they are doing
won't work out very well for them and
are anti-social and if you look at the
things we've destigmatized
the most obvious and first one is
divorce
um and the consequence of d still and
back in the sixties you know a divorcee
was looked upon as being someone rather
shady and seeding uh that's all gone
completely i mean i'm divorced i mean
most people are now divorced um
uh marriages simply don't last anymore
but it hasn't been to our benefit it
hasn't been either to the benefit of the
people who've got divorced and by that i
mean particularly the poorest of us for
the poorest of us divorce is
catastrophic financially and it
certainly hasn't been beneficial for the
children uh and we know from
a multitude of of uh of
social studies that
children from divorced parents end up
doing worse at school have worse
employment prospects and more likely to
get into trouble with the law than those
who are with parents who are married
you know who stay together so so that
didn't work we've also de-stigmatized
and this makes me sound awfully like
mary whitehouse i know uh cohabitation
and again i've cohabited you know i was
part of that generation which which
brought all this stuff
but again
cohabiting and then having children
means that those children are more
likely to see you split up than if you
were married i think it's a difference
between about seven years and 13 years
seven years if you're cohabiting is the
average expectancy of a relationship 13
if you're married
both of which are obviously too low and
again that brings in the same thing that
it's a bad outcome for the kids
um various other things which people are
trying to destigmatize the obvious one
at the moment is obesity
uh we're told that that
that it's wrong to
to uh uh
stigmatize people who are affected body
shame them to fat shame them and so on
and yet
perhaps that is one of the reasons why
we have such an obesity epidemic because
if you remove remove stigma
these things suddenly become normal and
and someone who is overweight
might well think that their body weight
is a normal weight because so many other
people have it and it's nothing to be
ashamed of but it's something to be
ashamed of because it will kill them
and because it's bad for society
well but rod where does that leave you
then because of the things that you've
mentioned you say you're divorcee you've
cohabited as well what are you knowingly
being stigmatized and okay without or
you think that you should be more
stigmatized or
how do you how do you reconcile that
well
i first started looking at uh
the effect of divorce
and single parent of single parenthood
is absolutely catastrophic for children
uh i mean in in so many ways and i
haven't seen a single study which
disputes this it's absolutely
catastrophic for children
um
and i first started looking at the
figures and the effects and so on
as i got divorced so in a way you know
it was it was provoked by my own
circumstances and i thought god you know
that this isn't the right thing to do
this really
wasn't the right thing to do
um
either one shouldn't have got married in
the first place and had children or or
one shouldn't have got divorced that
that that the outcomes for other people
um are very very bad similarly
similarly i have to tell you that you
know um i'm a bit overweight now but
nothing like i was in
2014
when my children were what were they 14
and 16.
and i had an argument with my youngest
son
you ended up telling me to
shut up you fat lady [ __ ]
exactly
were the words he said
and i thought god is that how he sees me
uh and over the course of the next year
i lost four stone uh by
doing 10 miles a day walking
stigma works you know being called fatty
it works well actually it also removes
the other crucial thing with obesity is
that in a sense if you destigmatize it
you remove from the individual their own
personal responsibility for how they are
and obesity isn't something which is
visited upon someone by an outside agent
agency it's not the consequence of
poverty that's a ludicrous assertion uh
it's it's
possibly some of it slightly tied in
with time poverty but i doubt that very
much it's not the consequence of
big multinational companies being evil
and feeding people horrible food it's
the consequence of eating too much and
not getting enough exercise and that is
down to the individual
well actually rod let's talk about just
my final question of what kind of stigma
works you you use you
quote your son's very strong words then
in your column you call obese people
sweating wheezing gargantuan lard
buckets do you think that kind of
language that kind of stigma works or
more gentler kind of judgments it's
probably more gentler
you know
i i do remember
[Music]
talking to
uh people who were my nieces they were
my nieces and they were
15 16 years old
and
uh we were out in the street and they
saw a girl who was
women 16 to 17 years old walking past
with a pram
and they said oh
single parent
and i thought well thank god for that
there is no aspiration on their part to
become a single parent
it's that it's it's just that innate
thing i don't want to do that because i
don't think it's good
you know and that's something
which stigma can inculcate rather than
having the government tell you you know
uh that's something that stigma can do
just
just make you think before you go down a
path which
excuse me
which which will be injurious to you and
injurious to society
well rod thanks so much
sorry have i won you over
or
or are you all still
full of a
verve to send the students out whoring
well as a member of the millennial
generation i don't think you can
fully win me over but we have run out of
time but we'll have to continue this
conversation another time rod thanks for
joining us tv bye
[Music]
you